[Music]
all right welcome
to the smartphone awards 2021.
so as you can see by the table in front
of me we've got plenty of smartphones
that have all come out in the past 365
days or so or at least the calendar year
in all shapes and sizes and well it's a
bit of attrition around here to reward
some of the best ones in a bunch of
different categories for a bunch of
different reasons to sort of incentivize
and show the best of the stuff that came
out during this year so we've got nine
categories and in each one of these
categories we're gonna have an overall
winner and that winner will get a shiny
super cool mkbhd edition trophy which is
sweet but then also we'll probably have
a runner-up and maybe even some
honorable mentions depending on how
close the category is honestly some of
these are
toss-ups but some of these are pretty
firm winners for sure but before we get
into all of that i do want to take a
moment of silence and remembrance
of lg see we always want more
competition in the smartphone space more
variety more options and so it's always
a bummer to end up with less than before
so let's take a quick moment to remember
when life was good
all right let's give out some trophies
so our first up category
is best big phone now we already know
most phones are pretty big that's not a
surprise but i do want to reward the
ones that make the best use of a lot of
space so if you're going to go out of
your way to get a bigger than normal
phone you really want a phone that takes
advantage of having that extra space big
screen big battery big specs and just an
overall good software experience to use
it all so
in 2021 we got a bunch of different
versions of this but the best big phone
for this year
was samsung's galaxy
z fold three and i'm really glad we have
a folding phone that's able to win
awards like this so obviously you've got
the big 7.4 inch display on the inside
and you close it up and you still get a
very usable display on the outside i've
talked at length about the idea of
folding phones and the benefit it can
possibly afford you and clearly they're
getting better every year the technology
is not perfect yet but fold three was
kind of the hard work king of all the
folding phones that came out like if you
made me pick a folding phone to use
right now full time it would without a
question be this one and it gives you
the best big phone experience of any
phone out here immediately as you unfold
it so huge shout out to the fold three
for being a real option for a lot of
people now i'm pretty firm on that being
the winner but i do have some honorable
mentions i'm gonna give a shout out to a
non-folding phone galaxy s21 ultra which
also came out right at the beginning of
this year as being
pretty much the standard big phone
experience big screen big battery big
cameras big specs and great software
everything about this phone hit all its
marks and i also want to give a shout
out to uh the gamer phone which has
continued to either top this category or
be right up near the top this is the rog
phone five one of the special editions
with this like matte white back but
they've done the same thing they always
do huge battery but it's also got a
screen on the back it's got triple
cameras it's uh it's a whole thing so
for the gamers who like the front-facing
speakers and the huge higher frustrated
screen this is definitely still top of
the list for people who are into that
so then next up best
small phone
now this is uh it's the opposite of what
we just went into clearly phone's been
getting bigger and bigger and it's more
and more rare to have a really good even
flagship level phone
that's small like genuinely small
and so i want to reward this this is the
thing that i sort of created a bunch of
categories for in the first place it's
like this phone might not get that many
awards without this category but i do
want to highlight it and so
i actually think this is my closest race
yet
it could have gone either way between
number one or number two but
i'm gonna give my best small phone award
my best use of not much space
to the iphone 13
mini so we already know what this is
about it's basically got all the same
specs as a larger iphone 13 but crunched
down into a smaller body iphone 13 is a
flagship this one has the same cameras
it's got the same performance it's got
basically the same screen just smaller
and it's all crunched down into a mini
phone and it fixed what we were really
complaining about with the last iphone
12 mini which actually won this award
last year which was a kind of weak
battery life by just making the phone a
little bit thicker and giving it a
physically larger battery all the things
we like about a mini flagship phone are
happening in the iphone 13 mini but it
was close and i'm telling you it's close
because it honestly could have gone
either way and i would have been totally
fine with it but i'm giving the
runner-up for best small phone this year
to samsung's
z flip 3. this is a small phone when
it's folded but when you unfold it you
end up with
sort of a
normal sized phone
now it's debatable how much utility this
has i mean you kind of use it the same
way as a normal candy bar size phone but
the fact that you're able to fit all of
that normal sized phone down into half
the size when it's folded and you get
the satisfaction of closing it and you
also get the ability to fit it into
smaller pockets smaller bags and into
smaller spaces makes this one a really
fun option i like this phone a lot
like i said i wouldn't choose it
personally if i had to pick one of the
folding phones but that's because i'm
not a small phone person so this one is
really compelling to see and they
dropped the price all the way down to
9.99 at launch which made waves so
another real folding phone option i'm
also going to give two honorable
mentions in this category for smaller
phones one to the oppo find n which was
released like literally right under
under the buzzer it just got in on time
but this is a smaller version of
basically the z-fold three and i really
liked it i talked about it a lot in the
video about how it might actually be a
preferred form factor and then the other
is actually the asus zenfone 8 over here
it's a pretty solid phone i mean it got
really deep in the blind smartphone
camera test like it does every year but
also it's just a nice compact size i
like the design and it fits in pockets
like some of these other bigger phones
don't if you're looking for a smaller
phone definitely don't count out the
zenfone 8. so okay next up
best
camera
who's going to get the camera award and
the smartphones this year i feel like i
kind of say this every year but i've
mentioned it recently on twitter and
i'll say it again it's kind of hard to
go
wrong really with almost any of the
options on this table especially if
you're spending premium smartphone money
you're probably getting a pretty good
camera and the differences come down to
subjectivity but for me there really
still is a clear winner for the best
overall smartphone camera system because
that's a whole package that includes not
just the apps that use the camera but
photo quality
low light videos low light photos
overall video quality different codecs
and formats available and just what you
would use to shoot videos with
if you had the option
this one's a no-brainer for me it's the
iphone
13
pro so the iphone 13 pro is actually a
pretty substantial jump up in the camera
department from the last iphone which is
also really good so it takes much better
photos you might remember the really
huge sensor from the 12 pro max last
year that's now the primary sensor in
these phones with the improved
stabilization and it also has these new
picture profiles which are super useful
for changing the look of the photos and
baking that in of course but then also
prores video i shot an entire video on
this channel during this year
on an iphone 13 pro with 4k prores video
super useful to have that available to
you so just as far as overall smartphone
camera package
i gotta go iphone 13 pro but i do want
to give my runner up to a phone that's
still to this day gets carried by i
think more
people in the tech world than any other
that i know because of its camera and i
still really like the photos it takes
and looks
and that is the pixel 6 and pixel 6 pro
the pixel 6 pro here also has that
telephoto camera some people like it a
lot some people not so much but just as
far as the the look of the photos the
contrasty
hdre computational look that you get out
of a pixel still some of my favorite
photos i've ever taken on a smartphone
come from these cameras so it's still a
google phone still making great photos
shout out to the pixel 6. i also want to
give two little honorable mention shout
outs one to the vivo x70 pro plus i
didn't get to make a video on the phone
this year but i'm going to give a link
in the description to a really good one
about it extremely interesting camera
setup and also just the overall phone is
well built but definitely worth checking
out that camera and also uh to our blind
smartphone camera test winner the pixel
5a which
beat the pixel 6 in the first round and
then just kept crushing right through
and eventually won in the finals so i
always do this it's on the table there
it is
pixel 5a
shout out to the blind smartphone camera
test winner so next category
best
battery best overall battery experience
this is this is for your power users
this is for people who need the phone to
last not just all day
but as long as possible maybe you want
to go a whole weekend on one charge
maybe you know you're not going to be
near an outlet for an extended
20 plus hour international flight all
this stuff you need the best overall
battery
there's a couple options here that are
going to do really well and i like to
factor in not just overall battery size
but now increasingly in this award
charging speed charging convenience
wireless charging all that sort of stuff
for just the best overall battery
experience
now that being said
our winner this year
is the iphone 13 pro max this is the
battery experience king so again
something apple did with their iphones
this year is bump up the overall size
and weight of their phones to include a
physically larger battery now on paper
it's not the biggest sale actually i
think it's about a 400 milliamp hour
battery or something like that but we
know what apple's magic has been doing
for the past couple years with their
silicon
and just optimization and these phones
just last forever so this is easily a
two-day phone for a lot of people
and if you turn off promotion and just
use it at 60hz all the time i can feel
confident going a whole weekend maybe
even three days on one charge on this
phone so that's super cool to see it
also has decently fast charging and also
supports wireless charging but the
runner-up has
yet again
the at least tied for the largest
battery of any phone that i tested that
came out this year that's the rog phone
five
six thousand milliamp hour battery which
is incredible to see it also has quite
fast charging but it does not have
wireless charging so that's something to
keep in mind but again the whole gaming
phone thing like they keep saying these
phones are supposed to be really great
just for gaming
and they are but a lot of the things
that are good for gaming are great for
the rest of the media experience front
facing speakers big higher fresh rate
screens huge batteries who doesn't want
that stuff so shout out to the gaming
phone so next up we have our
design award
this used to be uh this used to be the
build quality award and then it was like
the flashiest coolest design but now i'm
just it's just the design award this is
the best overall design and this award
is uh easily the most wide open totally
subjective it's just what i like and how
i feel about a phone's design and what i
think is my favorite phone design of the
year now there's a couple criteria that
go into that just for me i i've said
this before but i i couldn't give this
to a phone that has like a super
fingerprinty glossy back but there's a
lot of things about holding a phone and
just the way the the back feels even if
you're not looking at it the way the
camera bump protrudes or doesn't
protrude things like that a lot to
consider with a good design but it's got
to look good at the end of the day
and so my award winner for design for
2021 well that would be the samsung
galaxy s21 ultra right here grabbing
another award this phone was not only
one of the best big phones but one of
the best looking phones you can tell
it's matte black so it's got a soft spot
in my heart right off the bat but i kept
talking over and over again during the
year about how i really appreciated
samsung embracing the camera bump doing
something unique with it and actually
sort of making it look
really good honestly
it also has a great display that didn't
curve over the edges nearly as much as
previous generations which was nice also
the display goes pretty much corner to
corner center hole punch was fine with
me just didn't really make any mistakes
as far as design and holding it in the
hand there's also a subtle thing that
happens with a lot of the phones on this
desk where if the camera bump is just
the right size it kind of acts as a spot
to hold with your finger depends on how
big your hand is of course is just a
personal thing but i really like that
about this and several other phones here
nevertheless galaxy s21 ultra gets my
design award for 2021 but i do have a
couple runner-ups because i want to give
some shout outs to again things that i
think went really well one
oppo find x3 pro
just this simple camera bump on the back
here which was sort of sloped up you can
tell it wasn't
too jarring it just basically sort of
curved its way onto the camera plateau
on the back
really like that also like the blue
matte finish not a whole ton of dramatic
colors on this desk you might have
noticed so i'm a fan of when they do mix
it up i really like to find x3 pro here
also oppo again with the reno 6 this one
i just like the way it felt
just the the soft
satin soft touch back not a lot of soft
touch backed phones out here and then
let's just give a crazy design thanks
for taking a risk award to the legion
phone there's not a lot of phones like
this out there i still remember shooting
the thumbnail for this phone like you
can there's two usbc ports you can
charge it in
double wattage if you want or super fast
but it's a phone designed to be held
mostly in landscape there's a battery on
each side camera module in the middle
fans front-facing speakers this was a
it was a crazy phone but like in a world
where you kind of only have a couple of
shapes i'm glad we're still getting
weird crazy stuff like that so i gotta
at least shout that out so the next
award is going to be called the value
award
now this is a different name from last
year this used to be called the budget
best budget phone award and basically i
think the word budget means something
different slightly different for
everyone basically depends on how much
you want to spend but i'm calling this
best budget because this is just overall
best bang for the buck that's the
definition it can be any price it just
has to have immense value
so now the value award
actually goes to a phone that made its
sibling look pretty bad in value which
is kind of funny but it's the pixel 6
the standard google pixel 6. so you can
see why this isn't the budget phone of
the year it wasn't that cheap it was
5.99 but the value you got from this
phone at 5.99 with the tensor chip which
performed really well with this high
refresh rate oled display with these
really great cameras which matched the
pixel 6 pro decent battery life but also
just overall nice charging and nice
wireless charging this phone with its
great software made the pixel 6 pro
look like a bad deal
it was that good and so i highly
recommend this if you're looking in the
pixel line and this gets my value award
this is like a really easy phone to
recommend because of the price it
launched at now again this is a category
that's changed over the years and
obviously has a lot of competition
there's phones like the poco f3 which
have incredible value it's much more
along the lines of a budget phone and
deserves to be highlighted just for that
there's also the samsung a52s of the
world there's the realme gts of the
world just a lot of good overall phones
for less money i keep saying this good
phones might not be getting cheap but
cheap phones
cheap phones are getting good all right
so
the next category
the award you don't want to have to give
but hey
i'm giving it anyway it's the bust of
the year
basically the the worst phone to come
out this year maybe not the worst
overall phone actually but just the
phone that shouldn't have happened the
way it did i've given
all kinds of different phones this award
whether they launched at the wrong price
or had awful marketing or just were just
bad phones in general bad builds
whatever generally like i said it's kind
of hard to go wrong with a lot of the
stuff on this desk whether you're
looking at camera quality or battery or
value this is part of the thing about
living in the world of smartphones is
there's so many good ones to pick from
but
i have to give a bust of the year
and because i give a bust of the year i
have to give it to
the what is the 1500
uh surface duo 2. it's the microsoft
surface duo 2. so i remember when the
first one of these phones came out and
it obviously had one of the sweetest
hinges which is a really nice piece of
hardware one of the sweetest back
folding hinges of any phone we've ever
seen and so there's a little bit of hope
that it might be amazing and maybe the
second one would be amazing because they
didn't have cameras and i don't know
there's just a bunch of bugs with the
software but we'll give it some time
they launched the second one it's more
expensive than the first one
and it's worse
it's just not as good um and so i'm kind
of sad that it's not doing better like i
want to see a phone like this which is
dual screen instead of a single folding
screen work i think it's a cool idea but
as you could tell by the review video
there's still just too much unfinished
about it the software's still not great
the camera is just not very good i mean
to have those big cameras on the back to
sacrifice the full 360 fold and still
not be good cameras there's just no way
to recommend that phone
to most people lots of other things on
this desk i could just hand any of these
phones to most people i would just never
give a duo to to anyone i really liked
now next up this is this is one of my
favorite awards to give
the most improved award
and often what we'll see is companies
learning from their mistakes and
actually listening and doing a much
better version of something than the
year before it's actually happened a
couple times where a bust of the year
turns into a most improved award the
next year which is pretty cool to see
but this year's most improved award just
goes to a phone that did everything
better than last year
last year's phone not easy to recommend
this year's phone kind of doesn't have
any flaws they did a great job so the
most improved award is gonna go to
samsung's galaxy s21 ultra as a huge
improvement over the galaxy s20 ultra we
all understood what samsung was trying
to do with the ultra thing and when the
s20 came out and the s20 ultra was the
top of that line we saw the big numbers
and we saw the 100x on the camera and we
knew what they were getting at but there
were some weird autofocus issues with
the camera never really resolved
themselves and they ended up having to
add hardware in future phones for that
laser autofocus but generally hard to
recommend the s20 ultra s21 ultra comes
along and just nails it just everything
again they have a great screen great
battery great cameras that actually
focus and they still maintain a lot of
those super big numbers and the ultra
thing lives on so that's a huge
improvement over last year and you know
you generally you generally don't see
like massive year-over-year jumps big
gaps
uh between phones but i do have some
honorable mentions as well for most
improved one is gonna go to samsung's
z-flip three
not only did it become a much better
phone with this larger display and
better usability on the outside like
this is one of the things that made the
phone much easier to recommend but the
price also went down
that's huge that's incredible that you
don't usually see a phone make it a big
leap in usability and leap down in price
so i want to shout out the flip 3 and i
hope i hope other phones do that again
to be honest
i also will shout out iphone 13 pro just
because we got a much better camera
system
and a much better battery
and
i don't know how many years late but we
finally got the pro motion displays so
camera screen and battery sort of the
three most important things about a
phone all got bumped up on this year's
iphone pros
so anytime you can nail the fundamentals
like that you deserve a shout out good
job but we've got our most improved and
that s21 ultra so that leads us
to the final award of the night the
biggest one actually the sort of the one
we've all been waiting for which is the
mvp the phone of the year
now the thing about phone of the year is
again now we're drifting back a little
bit more into
subjective territory meaning it's not
just straight up the best phone to come
out during the year but if you think
about it kind of like the the mvp award
in a sports league maybe maybe the nba
or nfl or something like that it's a
little more about
that plus the impact you have on the
game
plus
the overall
like challenges you may have overcome
there's just a little more that goes
into the mvp plus a little bit of which
one was my favorite
so with all of that considered and
looking at all the phones that came out
this year in 2021
i think we got to give an acknowledgment
to a phone that came out right at the
beginning of the year and was one of the
absolute best phones you can buy at its
price the entire year
and that's galaxy s21 ultra from samsung
it's your mvp yet another award for this
phone but honestly it deserves it i
think it's really easy to forget about
the phones that come out in like january
february because
this is a year old at this point now
which is crazy to say compared to all
the other phones here but the price did
steadily drop a little bit i mean you
can buy this phone now for like what 700
600 bucks which is kind of insane and
it's really good at everything a big
flagship phone
should be good at it really doesn't have
any of the flaws maybe you might have
the camera be a little bit of a downside
or you might have the battery be a
little bit of a downside you know with
pixel it was the battery with the gaming
phones as the cameras like there's
always something there's always
something
but galaxy s21 ultra on top of having a
pretty great premium design to package
it all
nailed it they nailed it with this phone
now i do have a runner up for the mvp
the second highest voted in this
imaginary world where i'm voting on
these
uh and that is the iphone 13 pro
and again with this phone it comes down
to okay they took the three
most fundamental things about a phone
and made them all way better than last
year so overdue but they finally added
the promotion 120 hertz viable refresh
rate and it looks great with this
battery they made the phone literally
larger to have a much better battery
life doesn't necessarily charge super
fast but that might be nice to see and
then the cameras all got better
world-class cameras great photo and
video quality i wouldn't mind seeing
usbc or like having a charger in the box
but the phone itself
is really good and i really like using
the iphone 13 pro and then i also want
to give a shout out a sort of honorable
mention in the mvp category to
pixel 6.
i think this might be underrated as how
important this phone actually is this
year obviously this is the google phone
so we're looking at you know google
software all the stuff that comes from
having a pixel but also tensor having
your own custom silicon and that trend
moving forward and being 5.99 at launch
which is an incredibly good price
for a phone that basically has all the
flagship features you'd probably want so
why spend a thousand dollars when you
can have a phone for 5.99 that does all
the same stuff and so i i want to give
that shout out the best value phone is
also worthy as a second runner-up to mvp
phone of the year but that's it that's
it for my awards again this is all hand
selected by the entire judging committee
which is me so if you have any problems
with them let me know in the comments
section because i picked them all but
also we can talk about these i think
we're going to have a discord stages
event pretty soon maybe in the next day
or so so follow me on twitter or join
our discord channel if you want to be up
there and grab a mic and we can talk
about it
but generally
i think my sentiment is still the same
lots of really interesting phones still
coming out even though they're mostly
the same shape you know you still have a
rectangle slab but you get crazy weird
cameras or you get
gaming aesthetic or you get you know
tensor processor you get amazing
world-class design like there's a bunch
of different stuff available
and you kind of have a hard time going
wrong with a lot of it so shout out to
great phones for being a great reason to
be alive in 2021 that's been it for the
smartphone awards i've been your host
marquez brownlee thanks for watching and
i'll catch you guys next year
peace
[Music]